اذا خلال الخمس ساعات القادمه سوف يتم
الاعلان النهائي بانتهاء العمليه وكذلك
نجاحها وايضا تفاصيلها سوف تكون من قبل
الفريق الطبي الذي اليوم قام باجراء هذه
العمليه وهي العمليه التي تعد رقم 56 من
ضمن العمليات التي اجريت لفصل التوام
السياميه تحديدا في مستشفى الملك عبد الله
التخصصي في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه
لوزاره الحرس الوطني عموما سوف نكسب الوقت
وسوف يكون ضيفي وهو الفريق او رئيس الفريق
الطبي والمشرف عام عن مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه وكذلك مستشار
بالديوان الملكي الدكتور عبدالله ربيع
مرحبا بك يعني قبل قليل كنت تعلن عن اعلان
او بدل العد التنازلي فصل التوام السيامي
حسانه وحسينا وبالفعل تم ذلك الان ما هي
المراحل المقبله خلال الساعات القادمه
اولا مرحبا بك وبشاهد العربيه اولا الحمد
لله على
فصل التوام بانتهاء المرحله السادسه وكل
من التوام الان في سرير مستقل لاول مره في
حياتهم انا سعادتي اولا كبيره جدا
والسعاده الاكبر شاهدتها قبل قليل في عيون
والدي التوام انا اسميها دموع الفرح وهي
بالنسبه لي هي مكسب هذه العمليات كذلك
الشعور بالفرح للجميع من زملائي اعضاء
الفريق الطبي الذي يقدم لهم الشكر
والتقدير بالنسبه لما بقي من المراحل نحن
الان في المرحله السابعه وكما تشاهد اخي
هاني كل توام على طاوله وانقسمنا الان الى
فريق
لحسانه وفريق الحسين
للتحقق من التنسيق بين الفريقين واعاده
ترميم الجهاز البولي عظام الحوض كذلك
الجهاز التناسلي الامعاء نتوقع بعد هذه
المرحله يبدا اعاده تغطيه ان شاء الله
دكتور بشكل سريع يعني انت تحدثت انه هناك
صف اول وثاني وثالث الان نشاهد احد الصفوف
الفريق الطبي الذي تم تاهيلهم وتدريبهم
بشكل جيد واليوم يمارسونه مهنه فصل
التوائميه بعد وانتم تقودون هذا الفريق
يجب ان يكون هنالك استمراريه توجيهات
القياده هي البناء المستمر ان يكون هنالك
استمراريه ولله الحمد على مدى 33 عام
استطعنا ان نبني كوادر سعوديه في كل
الصفوف الصف الاول الصف الثاني والصف
الثالث وان شاء الله هذا البرنامج يبقى
دائما في احضان هذا الوطن الغالي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه دكتور عبد الله شكرا لك
اذا من داخل غرفه العمليات الخاصه بفصل
التوام السياميه حسينيه وحسانه كلاهما في
على سرير مستقل الان هي تبقى فقط الساعات
القادمه ويتم الاعلان النهائي بنجاح عمليه
الفصل وهي عمليه فصل سوف تكون رقمها 56
والتي سوف يتم الاعلان فيها خلال الاربع
ساعات القادمه تقريبا بعد اعاده ترميم
باقي الاعضاء من قبل الفريق الطبي الموجود
في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي بمدينه
الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه بوزاره الحرس
الوطني شكرا جزيلا لكم مستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي للاطفال في الرياض مراسل
العربيه نصفين شكرا يا هاني لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات